ja Frau Platin hat mich eben als
klimaaktivistin anmoderiert das ist ein
das ist richtig und falsch zugleich ich
bin vor allem ein Aktivist für die
Wahrheit ja der Wahrheit ins Gesicht zu
schauen die Erderwärmung ist ein Fakt
die Erderwärmung aufgrund der
Treibhausgase in der Atmosphäre die sich
anreichern die sich seit den letzten 220
Jahren fast annähernd verdoppelt haben
und die und das ist eine physikalische
Tatsache die einfach wie die Hitze unter
dem äh unter dem herdboden dazu führt
dass das Wasser im Topf irgendwann kocht
unseren Planeten erwärmen wie sich das
dann klimatisch wie sich das wettermäßig
regional und so weiter auswirkt steht
auf einem ganz anderen Blatt wir müssen
dieser Wahrheit ins Gesicht schauen und
das bedeutet zwei Dinge wir können das
Klima nicht retten und die Welt wird
nicht untergehen wir reden vom Prozessen
die Jahrzehnte und Jahrhunderte lang
andauern werden
Dinge wie Meeresspiegel
Anstieg der Meeresspiegel
Veränderung der Monsun der der
großwetterzonen und so weiter das wird
uns in diesem Jahrhundert und auch noch
in diesem Jahrhundert danach und dann
nach beschäftigen die Menschheit und
insofern ist wird auch immer Menschen
geben die sich mit dieser Sache
auseinandersetzen und deswegen gibt es
zwei Ziele zwei zwei Aufgaben die eine
Aufgabe ist wir müssen dafür sorgen dass
die Erwärmung der Erde des des Planeten
keine drei Grad oder noch mehr
übersteigt das können wir nur durch
einen Ausstieg kompletten Ausstieg aus
der
fossilenindustriegesellschaft der aber
nicht innerhalb von 10 oder 20 oder 30
Jahren zu erreichen ist sondern auch das
ist eine Aufgabe mindestens für dieses
und das nächste Jahrhundert das zweite
ist während wir dieses Ziel verfolgen
brauchen wir müssen wir uns anpassen an
die Veränderung des Klimas denn es wird
wärmer als die 1,5 Grad es wird wärmer
als die zwei Grad weil dahinter eine 8
Milliarden starke industriell getriebene
Zivilisation steckt der 8 Milliarden
Menschen sind wir auf dieser Erde und
erst dann wenn wir acht Milliarden dazu
bewegen sich insgesamt also ihr gesamtes
ihre gesamten zivilisatorischen
Strukturen Verhalten und so weiter zu
ändern werden wir auch aus dieser
fossilen
Industriegesellschaft aussteigen können
mein Appell ist Anpassung Ja sagen zu
den Veränderungen anerkennen dass wir da
nicht tun können es wird keine
Klimarettung geben wir werden damit
leben müssen wie vor 500 Jahren ja
unsere Vorfahren mit der Pest und
anderen nicht zu damals nicht zu
besiegenden Krankheiten gelebt haben wir
werden uns auf sehr vieles einstellen
müssen es ist ein bisschen so man kann
nichts machen aber man muss was machen
als Konsequenz wahrscheinlich haben wir
heute auch gehört das ist das aus jetzt
beschlossene Sache für verbrennermotoren
bis 20 35 war das für sie schon längst
überfällig
also was mich dann da kommen wir
bestimmt auch zu immer fraglich ist
schon vor vielen vielen Jahren ich kann
mich noch erinnern als
klein da gab es diese ganzen
Diskussionen schon und ich frag mich
immer wo ist eigentlich die ganze
Technik geblieben ja wir hat es gab
immer so diese Gedanken wenn du was
neues erfindest dann kommt die die
Ölindustrie und kauft das weg und packt
es ganz ganz tief in den Keller und ich
habe sogar das Gefühl wir bezahlen jetzt
schon damals wahrscheinlich war zu spät
jetzt den Preis dafür und ich denke es
ist einfach Zeit bestimmte Dinge noch zu
also endlich zu erschaffen oder die
Dinge rauszuholen lieber vielleicht
schon erschaffen haben wenn sie sich
wieder eine Verschwörungstheorie ist und
einfach mal nach vorne zu gucken weil
eins wenn ich 100% sicher das was wir
schon angerichtet haben da spielen wir
jetzt noch nicht mal den Schaden der
kommt ja erst die Frage ist wie wir
gemeinsam dahin kommen und ich glaube
nicht dass dieses sich auf den
Straßenfest Leben und die Menschen
penetrieren und terrorisieren auf ein
gewisser Art oder diese ständige links
grüne geredet dass das wirklich dazu
bringt die Menschen umzudenken und zu
Vernunft anzuregen ihre Verhalten zu
ändern ja also es gibt so viele Dinge
die wir verändern können und für die
Leute auch zu bereit sind aber es bringt
verbote bringen da nichts es bringt mir
Aufklärung und die Menschen zu animieren
um zu denken und so schaffen wir diesen
Prozess auch aber ich denke und das ich
glaube ich auch dafür die diese ganzen
die Erhöhung der Temperaturen und das
wird erst alles eintreten dass wir uns
darauf angewöhnen müssen wenn man sich
mal hinguckt was man alles so auf der
Welt sieht dann sind wir schon damit
drin aber dass da welche immer noch
total blind rumlaufen und sagen das ist
so nicht oder ich will das alles
weiterhalten also ich brauche keinen
Verbrennungsmotor ich würde nicht
unbedingt Lastenfahrrad nehmen aber Fakt
ist es bringt auch nichts wenn die
Elektroautos haben wo du nur 20 Minuten
fahren kannst und mein ganzes ganz viel
Kohlestrom ist das und natürlich und wo
kommt diese Batterie her wer muss denn
alle dran schaffen wie viel Wasser
braucht also irgendwie ist eine
Milchmädchen aus meiner Sicht und ja das
nutzt vielleicht der Grünen Ideologie
und auch dieser Partei gerade sehr stark
aber ich glaube das ist der falsche an
wenn wir die Menschen jetzt so versuchen
da so zu gehen wir müssen sie gewinnen
so vergraulen wir sie ja du schon ein
E-Auto bestellt ja nein aber ich denke
darüber nach in der Tat bloß man muss
sich den Strom Mix anschauen und wir
haben das jetzt durch den Winter ja auch
wieder erlebt dass wir im Dezember zwei
Wochen oder Ende November bis Anfang
Mitte Dezember zwei Wochen hatten in
denen die Sonne nicht geschienen und der
Wind nicht gewählt hat und ähm die ähm
der der Strom-Mix in Deutschland tief
braun war also 50% an einigen in einigen
Stunden sogar mehr als 50% kohleanteil
damit ist ein E-Auto erstmal definitiv
nicht sauberer als ein Auto mit
Verbrennungsmotor wir wissen z.B auch
hat VW ja selbst berechnet vor einigen
Jahren das ein E-Golf hunderttausend
Kilometer fahren muss bevor er
ökologischer ist als ein Auto mit
Verbrennungsmotor so und dann hoffen wir
mal dass die Batterie bis dahin hält und
nicht ausgetauscht werden musste dann
sind wir wahrscheinlich bei 150 160 000
km also zu glauben dass ein Auto
automatisch umweltfreundlicher ist als
ein Verbrennungsmotor das muss sich
wirklich erst nach einer langen langen
Fahrzeit und Fahrtdauer herausstellen
und die Diskussion hat das muss man
sagen um den Klimawandel wird hier bei
uns in Deutschland ganz schön emotional
geführt während andere Länder
Kohlekraftwerke bauen verliehen wir uns
ja manchmal auch in so einer
Emotionalität in dieser Diskussion die
Frage an Sie müssen wir da ist es unsere
Pflicht für dieses Ziel als
Vorreiterrolle dass wir voranschreiten
dass wir da auch eine Vorbildfunktion
für den Rest der Welt haben und glauben
Sie dass das dann auch überhaupt
aufgehen kann ja das ist auch wieder
sowas absolut deutsch ist dass
Deutschland immer ein Vorbild sein muss
ich weiß gar nicht wo das herkommt ein
Freund von mir meinte mal früher wollte
Deutschland die Welt erobern heute
möchte Deutschland die Welt belehren ja
und das so kommt mir das auch manchmal
vor und bei diesem Thema der das
Verbrennungsmotors der soll ja 25
abgeschafft werden das heißt es müssen
zwölf Jahre mich rechnen kann ich glaube
das stimmt das heißt die Politik weiß
jetzt schon wenn man das umrechnet sie
weiß jetzt schon was
Wissenschaft in zwölf Jahren zu machen
hat dass man auf diese Mutter Art
verzichten will und soll das weiß ich
jetzt schon also die weiß ich jetzt
schon offensichtlich dass der
Elektromotor auf jeden Fall durchgeht
vielleicht stimmt vielleicht stimmt's
nicht die Politik weiß jetzt schon dass
eflurs nicht marktfähig werden das weiß
ja alles jetzt schon ich finde das also
er hat schon eine gewisse fehlerische
eine gewisse da nach vorne gehende
Atmosphäre wo ich mir denke diesen Mut
hätte ich nicht also diese ähm ja diese
kurze würde ich mir nicht zutrauen aber
die Worte der Politiker muss man nicht
über die goldware leben heute sagen zu
der Zeit sind sie nicht mehr am Abend
sind dafür nicht mehr Verantwortlichen
also deswegen schöne politische Phrasen
die besonders grünen ideologischen
Interessen folgen aber ich sehe in der
Umsetzung nicht ich hoffe du kannst doch
erleben ja aber ich bezweifelt ist dass
es wirklich dann dazu kommt vielleicht
wenn die klugen Köpfe und auf unserer
Welt wirklich da sind was da finden dann
freue ich mich darüber aber ich glaube
es auch nicht dass es wirklich nämlich
diese Frage wird dann ja auch sein wenn
wir alle auf E-Auto setzen als 2035 geht
ja erstmal nur für Neuwagen aber gibt es
eigentlich genug Strom der hergestellt
wird gibt es noch geladen ist das erste
aber das zweite ist da gibt's genug
Strom gibt Studien auch in Deutschland
die sagen wir werden einen massives
Stromproblem laufen und beim Thema
Vorbild vollkommen richtig glaube ich
beim Thema Vorbild muss man sagen ist
der deutsche Weg ja schon ein wirklicher
Sonderweg in Europa wir machen diese
Energiewende seit mehr als 23 Jahren
jetzt 98 unter Gerhard Schröder rot grün
angefangen also sind im 25 Jahr und
müssen feststellen es gibt keinen großes
Industrieland außer Deutschland das
komplett aus der Kernkraft aussteigt
auch aus der Braunkohle und eigentlich
zu aller aller größten Teilen nur noch
auf erneuerbare Energien setzt weder die
drei Länder vor uns USA China und Japan
noch hinter uns Frankreich
Großbritannien und ein paar andere
setzen oder nehmen die Kernkraft raus
keines egal das Gegenteil selbst in
Japan dem Land mit dem großen Erdbeben
und dem großen Atomunfall werden neue
Kernkraftwerke oder sollen neue gebaut
werden da müsste sich glaube ich
Deutschland Fragen Stichwort Vorbild
nach 25 Jahren warum folgt uns
eigentlich keiner sind wir
möglicherweise der Geisterfahrer falls
man erheben wir das auch mal auf die
nächste Ebene sie sehen hier in dieser
Runde da ist so verhaltener Optimismus
was das Thema angeht aber was glauben
Sie wie sehen sie Deutschlands im über
die Anpassung gesprochen in 10 in 20 in
50 Jahren wenn wir so weiter also
momentan sehe ich vor allem dass wir so
verschleierungsdiskussionen führen ja
wir reden darüber wir stellen so rasch
wie möglich die auf auf E-Autos um und
damit ist im Kopf abgehakt psychologisch
Klima gerettet wir steigen aus dem Kohle
aus klimagerätet wir steigen aus der
Nuklearenergie raus wir bauen überall
erneuerbare könnte man jetzt verlängern
die ganze Reihe das sind Diskussion und
dann gibt's die moralische noch hier wir
müssen besonders viel tun weil wir ja in
der Vergangenheit als entwickelte Länder
besonders viel auch Schuld gehabt haben
ja da kommt dieses diese Liebe zur
deutschen Schuldiskussion heraus die
überhaupt nicht
irrelevant ist weil es vollkommen egal
ist wie wer wie viel CO2 der
Vergangenheit ausgestoßen hat es kommt
nur darauf an wie viel wir heute
ausstoßen wie viel wir morgen ausstoßen
was wir machen müssen in Deutschland
dann haben wir diese verzichts- und
verbotsreligion es kommt Religion sage
es ist schon
religi in dem Moment schon an
protestantisten das kommt schon von
unserer protestantischen Vergangenheit
her ist auch vollkommener Unsinn weil in
was wir uns verbieten und wir können ja
nur uns was verbieten vielleicht können
wir in der EU 550 Millionen Menschen was
verbieten ja aber wir können nicht 8
Milliarden was verbieten was wir uns
verbieten worauf wir verzichten ist von
der Auswirkung her reicht gegen 0 was
wir können und wohin wir zurückkommen
müssen damit mich durchaus optimistisch
wir müssen und das ist unser asset
unsere Technologie unsere technologische
Kompetenz einsetzen und entwickelt und
zwar völlig Ergebnis offen ja es gibt
leider leider so eine Tendenz gerade bei
den Grünen über so technologieoffenheit
zu verteufeln ja das z.B Atom an Energie
das ist abgehakt darf es nie wieder
geben
Film die Brennstoffzelle abgehakt darf
es nie wieder geben im Gegenteil ja die
Welt wird auf diese Herausforderung die
so massiv sind die so viel Opfer und so
viel Preise so viel Opfer hervorrufen
Kosten werden mit allem reagieren die
Welt ja möglicherweise wird deutsche
nicht ja aber da sind wir selbst schuld
die Welt wird die Kernfusion probieren
die Kernspaltung probieren den Salz und
Tore im Reaktion runtergehen die Welt ja
nur wir in auf unserer Insel wir
verlieren uns in diesen Schein und
schleierdiskussionen diskutieren Dinge
die überhaupt völlig ihre relevant sind
und müssen endlich damit aufhören dabei
ja noch muss man sagen ob es absolut
unehrlich wenn man den Chef der
Bundesnetzagentur hört der in einer
Beiratssitzung mit Politikern dann sich
freut dass die französischen AKW wieder
stärker am Netz sind hier aber
gleichzeitig in Deutschland dafür mit
trommelt er ist grünen Politiker und war
früher mal Umweltminister
Schleswig-Holstein und ist Robert habe
ich unterstellt und sich hier darüber
freut dass wir aus der Kernkraft steigen
da muss man einfach sagen das passt
einfach nicht zusammen gleiches Beispiel
im Thema Fracking Gas das holen wir uns
rein sind aber gegen das Tracking hier
in Deutschland also es passt überhaupt
nicht zusammen das ist wie sie glaube
ich ganz gut festgestellt haben man
schiebt das Problem weg um gleichzeitig
einfach das saubere Image zu haben wir
haben die weiße Weste bezieht aber diese
angeblich so bösen Energien und
Energieträger oder Energiequellen dann
aus dem Ausland und das ist natürlich
total verlogen